[Music]
you know how they play
[Applause]
all right today we are joined by Bruce
Rivers he's the criminal lawyer
one of my favorite YouTubers who I've
discovered in the last 12 months uh a
lawyer
um of 25 years I believe it's not right
Bruce that's right
um You have brought a real new breed of
content to YouTube where we're getting
the expertise of a man who's done this
for the majority of his life but with a
good sense of humor and I think you see
through a lot of uh these celebrities
perfectly well and one of the guys
you've covered a lot on your channel is
my old mate Andrew Tate
um and he's in a bit of hot water at the
moment so yeah they've charged him
finally
you've done a lot of um the videos on
them and explaining how his
self-snitching his constant boasting
about what he's done across his and I'm
going to use this term literally Korea
because he hasn't worked day in his life
really but you know is is this all
coming back to haunt him now I call him
the gift that keeps on giving because
every time he opens his mouth he really
thinks he's the smartest person in the
room right and uh and he you know to
prove this some of the charges I've
always said you need Force fraud or
coercion and what does he talk about in
in the instructional videos when he
tells all you guys how he set up his own
deal you know and he's like um don't
like him there's so many guys that just
lick each one of his nut sacks and and I
don't I really don't understand it it's
the guys you know clingy what color is
your Bugatti you know that kind of thing
they just really idolize the um the over
masculinity the uh the overindulgence
the the excessive wealth you know that
kind of stuff and so but when you really
break down what are you saying in his
videos you need to calm these women into
being uh subservient to you to love you
and to to do all these things to get
loyal to you so you can con them out of
their money
I mean that that is in a nutshell and
and that and look it is a real shame
that this man has been able to
um
obviously do what he's done to these
women for a start but also pulling the
wool over the eyes of it what seems like
a generation of young men who you know
it's it's a lot easier to do that when
you're selling a glamorous lifestyle
um and the ironic thing for me is what
what a true definition of masculinity to
me are people like yourself who who do
it the the honest way and the hard way
and put years and years of work in to
build themselves into a business and
build a family and stay loyal to that
family and and yet what what he has done
is is quite the opposite of that in
exploiting people he he is the grifter
who keeps on grifting and and to do an
instructional manual you know I don't
know if you've read his old website
where he takes everyone through you know
how efficiently he is in getting these
women to love him and then you know if
you've got a girlfriend you should do
the same thing
um and now he's obviously denying
denying as much as he can really
consistently he does interviews I mean
look I'm not a criminal but you know as
someone who's worked with them for years
it would seem like one of the best
courses of action is to keep your mouth
shut Bruce and yet you know as if you
were his lawyer how would you be feeling
right now
well first of all I don't think it would
be a slurp um and the only reason I say
that is because I don't think he'd
listen to me and it's very difficult to
handle a case when your client is always
stepping on themselves you know look at
look at what Trump's doing right now you
know doing the interview that he did
with Brett Bear the other night was just
absolutely ridiculous
um and and and and so anything you say
is going to be used and held against you
in court and so that one of the things
we did in our videos is we we take the
uh the charges and there's a really good
80 page order from the judge on tape on
why he's keeping him under uh house
arrest and
and in that there's a bunch of different
things that uh you know there's text
messages between the parties and
everything but one of the things that
we've done is we okay so he says he's
innocent he says he's never said that
because you saw the BBC interview that
he recently did well you just go to the
clip you know just go to his own words
and people are saying well that's just I
don't give a [__] if it's stick or not
he's telling people what he has done and
there's evidence to corroborate what
he's done and so what you know I don't
want to see anybody or bad things happen
to anybody but he's making he's His Own
Worst Enemy
yeah I think the the narcissism level
we've seen in him where you've got a man
you know much like
um you know serial killers when they
finally start singing uh they want to
tell you how genius they were in all of
their conniving plans and he really
comes across just like a classic Netflix
uh person who you think you're the
smartest man in the room so much so you
want to tell everyone just how smart you
are and in doing so incriminate yourself
and when you've got these manuals of how
to do this and how to coerce women and
then you've got a whole host of women
they're saying he did this to me I've
got the tattoo to prove it and I'm I've
been locked in there I've had to give
him all the money and all of these
things I mean I'm not a lawyer you are
but to me that doesn't seem that hard
approving Court am I wrong or no
here's the proof is in his own words and
his own instructional videos and you
match that up with what he did the other
thing he said is I have to do this in
order to cover up what I'm really doing
and so that he doesn't he doesn't pay
taxes I mean that he said that to one of
the girls yeah he said that on a video I
see like I see him talk about Bitcoin
and how you avoid paying taxes I mean
what we might be looking at is the tip
of the iceberg because when you look at
this man he wasn't a businessman by his
own admissions he was a struggling
kickboxer who even is kickboxing uh
record is is padded with the easiest
fights possible everything about this
man is a lie essentially and um and even
going back to the BBC interview he did
recently he actually says in that
interview I'm not going to answer that
question I'm not going to incriminate
myself and you're like how can you
incriminate yourself if you're innocent
in terms of
um this thing this this thing that
people say of it's just an act it's it's
not real it's not really who he really
is and some of these girls have then
come out uh you know a lot of these
women who he said he's had on the on his
books for 10 years I now defending him
saying he's a great guy but how will
that stand up in court him saying it was
all an act it'll rest on a couple things
one it'll rest a lot of it will rest on
these conversations he said on WhatsApp
um to get women to come you know you'll
be mine you'll be mine alone and then
and then you take the emails and text
messages and other things between his
brother and uh the other two ladies that
are are indicted with him
um they put that all together in a
package and uh and here's the thing they
you don't get a jury you don't get you
don't get some unsophisticated uh
housewife from the suburbs who's gonna
you know I who who you know will give
you the benefit of the doubt you you get
a judge and my understanding is that now
you know he's had one judge uh that has
been
um
his judge throughout this thing and when
it comes to the trial he gets a
different judge for that a judge is not
going to take the political heat to
acquit him
um
and it and so I just his chances of
winning this I think are slim to not
a lot of people are speculating that
they with the amount of money he has
which even that seems incredibly vague
and inflated
um a lot of that is like you know you're
looking at him living in a 600 000 pound
house and claiming hundreds of millions
of pounds of wealth a lot of it just
doesn't add up and you know I understand
uh a lot is is for sure but
the deal could be offered to him
essentially from what I'm hearing on
Google and do my own research that you
know you give up what you're worth to
cut a deal to get you a lower sentence I
mean I don't know what you understand of
Romanian law but do you think that's
probable
yeah I think it is I mean the I know
they've seized um
I mean 13 or 14 cars
um and but it on the flip side of that
they didn't seize a lot of cash
um you know because I don't think he had
a lot yeah it's all being used to put up
the show I guess yeah and so
um
if he put all his money into cars how
smart is that and so I I would assume
you know and I've done deals like that
before I had a guy who was dealing uh
you know marijuana for eight years so
100 pounds a month and he put everything
into his home and stuff and it was all
cash and so I struck a deal you know
okay we'll give up everything
um and you give him some home monitoring
time and that's it so that's a
possibility but given how high profile
this uh how high profile this is I
really doubt that that they're going to
let him buy his way out of jail and do
you think him repeatedly calling it the
question the validity of the trial
saying they have no evidence the things
he said in the past about I'm moving to
Romania because of the laws over there
being so Lux
um how dumb is that the fact that people
call him a genius man this guy one of
the dumbest people I've ever seen and
then he he does this um you know he's
constantly sort of insulting the people
of Romania who are behind this lawsuit I
feel like they're gonna wanna and I
could be wrong and look if he's innocent
I think you know even as much as I
dislike him if he's innocent find him
innocent okay but the reality is I doubt
that's going to happen because there's
so much out there that proves and points
to him being involved in illegal
activity the Romanian people will
probably want to make a statement out of
him saying this is not a paradise for
criminals we will not allow this uh what
do you make of that
oh well here's the other thing they're
part of the convention uh the U.N
convention on uh sex trafficking and I
I've actually tried a sex trafficking
case where I had uh you know five other
coder four or five other co-defendants
it's a seven week trial so I I know what
this convention is and I know um exactly
how these cases are tried and you know
there's how long would it last usually a
case like that do you think
at least five six weeks I would bet
um but to get a trial may take longer is
that correct or no
I think they're gonna no I think they're
gonna get into trial fairly quickly here
oh all right so we'll have an outcome
and do you have any estimations of um
you know how long if found guilty if he
could be looking at here
you know I I think he could be looking
at 10 years plus
wow and and this when you hear that and
you see the way he's behaving even now
he seems in a state of absolute delusion
where he is comparing himself to Phillip
Schofield who's a TV presenter in the UK
why would you do that why I saw that why
that he would see was he a uh the story
behind that is he was like a breakfast
TV guy who had been allegedly grooming
uh a a young man who by the time they
had some sort of relationship I think
was of legal age but equally you're
comparing yourself to a groomer and it's
like he's going well they they're
treating that groomer better than they
treated me and it's like well
you're supposed to be this Uber
masculine man and you're crying out here
about them treating other people better
than you I mean
I I just did a video on this and and you
and you see him comparing him side by
side and to this guy and I don't really
know Scofield I don't know his story
very well but you know from what from
what he said just he's a you know sex
offender and uh and
he's comparing himself to the treatment
in the media and it's like this is why
you don't want your client giving public
statements like this because it's just
and he you know the media blitz and it
it just there's nothing he can say
publicly that will help him in court
yeah he didn't put a video package out
when he first got you know uh uh charged
and you I mean obviously they've been
working on this for some time so he was
expecting it and it's like you're you're
basically a glorified pimp that's what
you've become in your life and he
doesn't have a shirt on in in that
public address and then he's comparing
himself in this video too Johnny Depp
world famous actor uh Cristiano Ronaldo
world famous soccer player and you're
like me you're a glorified pimp who made
your business as that yo it's not like
this is just randomly happened to you
and you were you know accused this is
like several people have accused you
it's not one girlfriend gone wrong and
you've literally publicized this and I
don't know how people can be so stupid
to even take in another word he says is
it possible that the Romanian police
have evidence they haven't released yet
to The Wider public because all I know
is what we've found on YouTube
essentially
um I there's some guy in Romania that's
been sending me stuff and then you know
but then I also got the order from the
court and it sort of coincides that 80
page order is the most damning uh thing
and it it actually goes through these
conversations you know little by little
and then and then it talks about his own
words what he says on his videos and
then it also talks about the things that
they found and uh and the methods that
he's been using so I I think they have
way more than they need to prosecute it
okay that well I mean because some of
the vice notes I've heard where he's
sort of
um his message ago saying I love
you like you know that one that message
I love you know attacking you
essentially uh sexually and then and
then the voice notes the sick voice
notes he sent which his fans are then
saying now ai and just in this complete
state of delusion but
um you know the the testimonies that
I've heard from the women where they're
crying and talking about I don't know if
you've seen the BBC uh interview with
one of the the girls who was a victim
who was sobbing I mean you're probably a
great judge of character at this point I
don't know if you've seen any of those
women give their statements but did you
feel like you were leaning to believe
them or not you know they don't have to
be corroborated there's a big misnomer
that what they say has to be corroborate
but it seems to me that they are
corroborating and uh why don't they have
to be corroborated
they don't because it's their testimony
it's just their credibility you know if
you if you if you look at them and their
their demeanor they're uh if what
they're saying makes sense if uh if and
if there is corroboration that's just
more icing on the cake but what I what I
have come to to Come Away with is is
that he's so much blustered right I'm in
so many promises of of X Y and Z and and
it's attractive to some ladies right and
and some ladies will go ahead and be
humiliated or
um endure you know poor treatment have
you seen the video of him slapping the
the blonde female yeah yeah right I mean
he apparently met her when she was
around 16 and you know she to this day
defends him and says oh it was just game
it was just game and I'm like you're
still in his game and I don't even think
you're aware of it like she's so loyal
to him and to like she's so while
getting smacked in that video and you're
like you really like you really think
that you were enjoying that you and I
feel like she doesn't even realize the
level of brainwashing that she's been
subjected to
well that that's a whole other issue and
I I would bet that the that the
government's lawyer in this case would
have experts to talk about brainwashing
and how these girls are um are trapped
you know the same Collision sorry to
interrupt you mate like what what
exactly is coercion to someone who
doesn't know
coercion can take a couple different
forms it can take like a physical form
like I I limit where you where you go I
physically punish you I you know that
kind of thing but it can also take the
form of
um debt and in the case that I tried
nobody was forced to be there I mean and
it was all about debt because when you
when they got here they owed a certain
amount of debt and they had to pay that
off and then once they did them they
could do what they wanted but until then
they couldn't and that is what that's
one of the allegations in this case
about the sex trafficking is that these
women were saddled with a bunch of debt
uh and then they had to pay it off how
would that be in debt
yeah
uh that's a good question I don't
exactly know how you know the structure
of the dead but that's one of the things
that that order talks about is that
these uh women are you know to get the
opportunity to do what they want maybe
to buy into the business they get a
certain amount of debt and then they
have to pay it off so that's so debt is
one thing uh so like you buy things for
them and then say you have to work this
off now no no no no you say I'm gonna
I'm gonna bring you here I'm gonna I'm
gonna fly you here I'm gonna pay for
your expenses I'm gonna pay for your uh
and you're gonna owe me x amount of
dollars and they and then when they do
that they do it in such a large amount
that there's no way you could ever pay
it off so yeah it forces you to stay in
that situation but the other thing is
they took their passports
um they uh you know they they were under
constant surveillance they were never
left alone and and so they were their
freedom was severely restricted so when
you get those a combination of those
things that's coercion
and then you've got those two females
who are also involved in this high up as
the former police officer one who's in
her 30s
um that's a very interesting one because
I was wondering like at what point
could they flip and turn on him and sell
him do you think now the closer we get
the trial they might break or are they
in it for the long haul now in your
opinion
you know
I it's it's a good question no one knows
except for their lawyers I would be I
would be shocked
well the only way they're going to flip
is if they're offered something to flip
and and if the if the prosecution
doesn't need it they're not going to
offer it
right yeah because they'd rather get the
whole group of them anyway
right yeah but if if they I I would I
would bet that her lawyers have have
broached that subject because it it they
would be it would be malpractice if they
didn't yeah it baffles me why these
people have remained loyal but then I
don't know what what he has on them as
well because they were probably doing a
lot of the dirty work and maybe maybe
they have enough and when you look at
the I mean just looking through some of
the evidence here I've got in front of
me you know between all of the victims
statements uh there was six to seven
statements taken they were making 50
Grand a month and obviously not being
giving much of that the Tates seem to
have spun this on their little video
saying oh we're getting
um they're they're saying that we did it
for their money for their tick tocks and
you know Tick Tock doesn't even make a
lot of money what do you make of this
sort of misdirection and the spin that
they're now trying to create by getting
public opinion on board with them
well first of all polycopene won't
matter in the courtroom number one
number two be if you if you remember
what he says in one of his videos how he
scammed them out of their uh out of a 20
30 percent
oh I I need you to sign this tax form
and I need you to sign this tax form
because what I'm going to do here is say
I'm going to pay your taxes and he
doesn't pay taxes but he takes another
chunk of their money so it that's
another form of Fraud and so the fraud
can take a number of forms but the so
the the prosecution does not have that
far to go in order to prove what they
need to prove for the sex trafficking
part of it and with it just being a
judge and the the judge previously had
said the reason he was keeping a hold of
him
um which I mean obviously in on a human
rights level without charges uh I think
you know even me and you who aren't a
fan of this guy were a bit surprised by
you he previously had said the capacity
and effort to exercise permanent
psychological control over the victims
including resorting to acts of violence
were there reasons why so the judge
certainly doesn't seem to be in the this
could go either way frame of mind on the
run-up to this trial there's two um
considerations when you talk about bail
or detention and one is a danger to the
public and that's what he's talking
about there and the other one is risk of
flight and that was also addressed and
if you remember I think he had like
seven passports you know from various
countries so he had and he was a UK
citizen a U.S citizen uh so he had a U.S
UK Romania and he had several other ones
for other countries I don't know how he
got those passports but and he bragged
about it and he bragged about he didn't
go to any country that he wanted to I
mean I'm sorry you know
you know [__] around find out
yeah and he he even said like uh well
there's many Clips I'm saying like if
they're trying to arrest me like he's
talking about his lawyers like get me
the [__] out of here and like he's
basically like if they put me in in jail
I'm just gonna buy my way out I mean it
does feel like the Romanian uh police
would have seen all of that now and he
was specifically talking about the
Romanian
um authorities and and the jail I will
walk into that jail and I'll have
everybody you know doing this like okay
and then and now right he run on a
Bugatti scooter it's very interesting
because obviously last time he was
locked up with just his brother this
time oh it gonna be different boy you're
gonna be in there with the real killers
the real dogs and uh and he'll be you
know fresh meat and and a prize if
anything that some of these Bad Dudes
um and look you know anyone who's been
offensive to women and bill
I'm not sure it's the best look
especially when you've been seeing what
you've been saying in terms of just this
is public
um actions because obviously the the
evidence is pretty dumbing he's now like
he's putting out tweets saying things
like oh I'll train Elon Musk for a
celebrity boxing match uh that's his
most recent tweet before we've done this
interview and you're just thinking like
you're not even close to being in the
real world here no I think he's getting
a little desperate for cash that's my
guess okay you know and and it just it
it just breaks my heart to see these
young guys idolize him and sign on to
hustle University or whatever is like a
scam is you know you'll be surprised
whenever I put out a uh a gift that
keeps on giving video about Andrew Tate
um I always get these comments you know
and you know from guys saying oh you
just don't know him or you're jealous or
you know and and they're just hook line
and sinker into his world and these guys
will never own a Bugatti they you know
and the stuff that he sells it's just
not it's not real it's just it's such a
fake hype and uh and that's why I'm on
my channel but I I promote is building
you know building a life building your
your financial future building your
education building your relationships
just buildings that so you look back in
a few years it's like look what I built
that makes it it's for young guys they
make better choices when they don't want
to do that unfortunately though and
that's part of the thing when you can
the the reason Tate can sell to these
young impressionable guys is there's
there's not the attraction there for
laying a brick in your house every day
to build a house over a long period of
time people want the instant they want
the immediate they want the quick cash
and that's what he sells that's what he
sells to those girls that's what he
sells to those young boys and it's he's
the Pied Piper and I'm it's been
incredibly frustrating for me because
I'm the one who's had a lot of his fans
saying this and the other about me
because I I actually pointed it out
about him in my first video back in what
2019 I first discovered this guy had
about 20 000 subscribers and I said like
I'm getting all Kelly vibes from this
guy he's deliberately seeking out these
young impressionable women there's not
educated women of real high value and
high self-respect who are going places
in their own life and don't need a man
they're not picking this guy he's
picking the pretty ones who didn't have
a dad who no offense but you know who
are struggling and looking for that
strong meal and and I watched a it might
have been a Jordan Peterson clip where
he talked about men who are
um Psychopaths essentially they can put
extreme confidence to young women and
women will mistake that confidence for
confidence because they don't be they're
not able to descend between the two of
them and I think he is a living example
of that kind of to sell yourself in the
best way possible and if the reality is
nowhere in the other it doesn't matter
because people aren't smart enough to
know the difference aside from people
like yourself of course and yeah what do
you think about the youth impact that he
is having right now because people seem
to be sort of I don't know not not
believe not really understanding the the
damage he is having It's just sad
because he's he's a caricature of
success
and and not real success not something
you could really apply in your daily
life how many of these guys are actually
going to start an only fans page or you
know or start a webcam business I mean
it's not replicable and for a start you
know his his methods were illegal so
this isn't something you can try and
test in your own life and that's why him
selling it is more laughable than
anything and when you look at what he's
been able to do with look I understand
there's been a feminization uh from how
civilized the world has become and now
we have social media where people don't
have to be accountable to what they say
to each other and he is capitalized on
that by being this Paul our opposite so
that people can who are sick of that
have an outlet in their mind of oh well
I'll follow this guy because he speaks
to me more than the the feminists and
all of the the other people who seem to
be taking over online right now there's
a lot of lost men who feel like
um probably emotionally and biologically
they're still they belong in a different
era to where they are now when they
can't really figure out how to behave
like men so they're looking to people
and he is you're waving over here yeah
I've got the right answer and clearly
not but when you talk about uh the sex
trafficking specifically uh would that
you know in the UK they have what's
called a sex offenders register where
people who molested kids and whatever
have to sign on would that mean he'd
have to sign that for example 100 I
wouldn't be surprised if he's got
charges pending in the UK and and
possibly the US yeah well this victims
from both sides aren't they so they'll
be yeah
I think they're probably just waiting to
see what happens in Romania but you know
and I I just I just don't know when it
became fashionable to treat women like
[__] you know to hit them you know what
it is still right it's because there's
more For What from what statistically
I'm learning about is dating and uh
social media has changed the world so
much so now like women are uh aiming
higher than ever because they're they're
saying what's available because of
Instagram it's not like the old days
where we were just you know meet a girl
at a dance or at a nightclub or whatever
so so the amount of men who can attract
women seems to be getting smaller so
therefore there's more virgins than ever
right and these virgins they want an
answer and they've got a guy being like
hey guys you know this is how it's done
this is how you do it with the ladies
and there's a lot of these pied Pipers
who are Charming these young men and
thinking that the way they go is to be
an [__]
and actually making women laugh and
being nice to them is paying for stuff
is actually probably a better way but
I I think humor is probably the biggest
aphrodisiac for women
[__] yeah have you ever seen an ugly
guy with a hot woman he is a guaranteed
good laugh
um obviously this human trafficking
thing you've done these these trials
before
um I mean what percentage chance do you
give Andrew Tate for being found
innocent
zero
zero I I just you know people say well
they don't have any evidence you know
and well they do have evidence
somebody's testimony is evidence you
know as the women come in and testify to
what he did and how he impacted their
life and how he uh you know kept them
isolated both financially and uh
physically and and how it and and how he
made all these promises to them that
were all [__] and we're all
intentional lies I I think it's gonna be
very hard for a court to ignore it and
and remember he doesn't get to have 12
um
12 Minds 12 independent Minds who are
going to look at this thing you know
from a bunch of different directions
they get into one shot with one touch
and you know
I just he's not going to have the
benefit of the normal jury system that
we're used to it feels to me and correct
me if I'm wrong when people say
um you know there's no evidence what
they're meaning is there's not an actual
video tape of him committing this act on
a woman but like all right okay but
that's why proving sex attacks is so
difficult and that's why the evidence is
often
um lost or not found in time but you
know because time is of the essence and
these sort of things for DNA but when
you look at a guy who's promoted himself
to do this has told you how he coerces
women has given a course on how to do
this you've then got messages between
him and the victims in question where he
is saying I loved you last night the
voice notes you've then got all of their
injuries all of their issues the fact
that they were there the fact that we
can prove them there we can put them
there we can show that they were earning
money for him that then went into his
account like when people say there's no
evidence I'm like what I mean what more
do you want aside from a literal video
of it
you just laid it all out you just laid
it out perfectly they don't
you know look at the facts objectively
you know and I've looked at them
objectively and and the first thing he's
going to want to do let's just talk
about a defense what does this defense
look like and the defense the defense is
going to be you know they were there
voluntarily
um everything they did was consensual
they made money and it was an
opportunity for them that's going to be
their defense and then and and they will
probably have
many positive messages
from other girls and then they're going
to try to have other girls probably try
to discredit them that's going to be
their defense but I think it's going to
fall short that does make a lot of a lot
of sense I mean what what else could he
go for realistically before we move on
from
um if he was to get 10 plus years do you
have any idea of how many years you'd
actually serve
I I don't I don't know I don't know what
the uh if they get good time in Romania
or not but um but from what I understand
and I've seen a couple interviews with
guys who've done some time in Romania
and it's it doesn't sound like it's a
pleasant place to be no no I interviewed
a guy who'd done time in Romania and he
he basically said because of the
prosecutor that they've got on board who
was basically a pit bull he's like they
wouldn't have even arrested him if they
didn't know for a fact they were going
to get a conviction because that's the
way this guy sort of operates he's a is
is one of those the best guys that they
have obviously have you done a sex
trafficking case like this before where
you were Prosecuting or defending and
what was the outcome
well I I can't ever see myself putting
people in jail that's not in my DNA so I
defend always and the one that comes to
mind I had a seven week sex trafficking
trial uh it was all time it was related
to Thai women and my clients set up a
few my client was a Thai woman she and
she was a sex worker herself and she set
up how a few different houses and and
um would have uh these gals work for and
she worked right alongside them and the
issue in that case wasn't whether she
did what was being alleged the issue is
whether it was force fraud or coercion
and they said that the debt uh we she
wind up getting convicted but the
guidelines it was it was worth trying
because uh we educated the judge as to
what the case was about basically and
she was looking at uh well over 20 years
like 270 months I think was the top end
of the guidelines
and uh and I got her under under 120. so
so we beat the guidelines we beat any
offer and yeah what sorry how many years
120 120 months oh wow okay so for 10
years just under 10 years and
but by the time we got to trial she had
you know three or four years in already
so she only need to do a little more
time and she was out but
um it was a really fun trial in the
sense that we had uh you know Five Guys
five or six guys and um it was the
camaraderie and the the the [__] that
happens in court is just it just I I'm
telling you they make movies about what
we do they don't make movies about uh
you know accountants generally speaking
yeah and it's but it was fun it was
really a fun fun trial uh the best line
out of this was this guy wanted it to
arrange it uh you know a time to go see
one of these ladies and he asked if she
can wear the shoes that she's wearing in
the ad
and I don't have the [__] shoes could
he come to [__] me or the shoes
and I said that sounded like a powerful
woman to me you know yeah yeah buddy you
know you you often will have to defend
bad people essentially
um because everyone has the right to a
defense and you have probably at times
gotten someone
a an innocent verdict who may not have
officially been innocent in you know and
that's part of your job is to do your
best do you ever question that as a on a
moral level with yourself
no that's just future marketing if they
go uh commit more crimes I get more
business
I'm kidding about it
people will look at you and go damn that
guy he did a great job because they were
psycho you know like it almost is isn't
it
it doesn't happen as often as you think
um the federal government the U.S
attorney's Office in the United States
their conviction rate is like 96 or
something like that it's it's insane
um the um I had 10 trials last year I
won seven out of the ten
um and one civil case where my client uh
was awarded 35 million on a burn case he
was burned
um on 40 of his body in a work-related
accident but the other the other nine
trials were all criminal cases
um and you don't win them all I mean you
can't win them all and if you win them
all if you anybody who's there's only
two luck kind of a liar Flyers there's
only two kinds of lawyers
this is really Jim Carrey's stuff right
now right yeah there's only two kinds of
lawyers who have never lost a case liars
and [__] those are the two kinds of
Lords I had two cases last year that
were really bad homicides and very big
verdicts for the prosecution I mean and
so
um so if if I win a case and I know my
guy did it you know or was actually
guilty
um that's not on me that's on the
prosecution for losing the case
because the burden is not on me to put
on a defense the burden is on the state
to uh uh to prove the guilt
I mean yeah you make a very good point
and ultimately if you're able to do that
then then you're doing the right job you
know for for your client
as Thomas Jefferson said better to let
uh 10 guilty uh go free than one
innocent be imprisoned
it's a tricky one isn't it it really is
a difficult system to live within and I
definitely want to get you back on for a
more in-depth talk because I think that
this is such a fascinating topic I mean
we love crime documentaries for this
reason and and I'd love to go through
more of your career uh just one last
question before I'll let you go
you know when you look back at your
legacy as a lawyer
um
and I'd like to talk more about just The
Man Behind that book just as a lawyer
what is your legacy and your opinion
amongst your peers amongst the way
people see you as a lawyer
um
somebody who is a tough strident
Advocate who played by the rules and uh
and dealt with everybody in a fair and
uh and sometimes jocular way
I like to make people laugh wherever I
go man we know we know that anyone who's
watched your channel and it's a
fantastic Channel I will put the link in
the description below for people who
want to go and check out because you do
you break down a specially celebrity
trials which there seem to be a lot of
weirdly uh yeah this is an abnormal
amount of criminals getting popular
um but no uh I will put a link for the
Bruce reverse channel uh below I can't
wait to have you on again I'd love to do
when we've got more time and you're not
so busy to sit down and talk about your
entire career
um talk about the highlights of your
career and and some of the big moments
that you've been through and just
overall the justice system and hopefully
we can do that soon mate
I I can't tell you uh how much I
appreciate meeting you and uh you've
been at my my son Michael Rivers who's
our content genius
um has been a huge fan of yours for a
lot of years oh big love to him then and
uh well done on everything he is killing
it on your channel doing a fantastic job
uh so yeah thanks for uh to everyone who
tuned in we'll be sure to do a part two
soon and we'll see us later cheers
thank you
foreign